removing someone's loan it might seem
small to others but it's not just moon
moon with helping people we have been
able to reach about 600 kids nationwide
or more free loans in their community I
mow lawns in all 50 states
I Drive 248 and I fly to the last kind
of why I'm actually on my six 50-state
tour this tour that I'm calling on
inviting police officers out the mall
with me as a way of building
relationships between police officers
and the communities my name is Rodney
Smith junior I'm on free loan for the
elderly disabled single parents and
veterans back in 2015 I came across the
elderly man outside moon is long and
looked like he was struggling so I
pulled over and helped them out that
night I decided this was bigger than me
I wanted to get kids involved and
encouraged both boys and girls to get
out there and make a difference one one
at a time
the overall mission is to use the
program as a way of giving back
we have 500 kids quantity take apart for
the our challenge the 50-yard challenges
the challenge that we have issued the
kids nationwide to mobile phones in
their community
for my last 350 state tours I've had a
specific theme the homeless the veterans
and now for my six 50-state tour I'm
running with cops I decided I'll make a
special lawnmower that lights up like a
police car and the response has been so
well-received
in almost every state I had police
officers come out and move me
given our current climate it's important
to put a human face on our law
enforcement and the young ones who is
helping by showing them that they too
can give back to the community and help
those who are serving the community as
well if a kid sees a police officer
coming to his neighborhood with a
lawnmower that lights up I believe that
it's gonna start a conversation and the
kid that normally won't trust the police
officer now he's interacting with a
police officer and now they're building
that relationship I think lawn care and
community policing go hand in hand
are you guys ready all the ones that
I've moved since the start has been
about 2,000 plus loans if we combine all
those loans and all the Kids Corner
taking part in the program will be about
25 thousand wrongs move free before I do
the goal is to inspire others to get out
there and make a difference it doesn't
have to be wrong here I've simply chosen
a lot more to make a difference with and
I helped encourage kids and adults to
make a difference one at a time I never
get tired doing what I do
[Music]